I
hey guys I'm Greg and I'm John so we're
making a little special announcement
today for a long time now ever
especially since the algorithm change
happened with YouTube I'm sure some of
you have heard about last week I posted
a video called vented about all this
YouTube crap and that's been more than
ever a lot of subscribers and this was
suggested from the subscribers for a
while now but especially after last
week's or like you know what let's just
do if John and I haven't been the most
you know could be perfectly transparent
not the most comfortable with wanting to
start up one of these but we're like
bucket so many subscribers seem to be so
supportive of it so we launched the
patreon account whoo we got one of them
patreon account but the way how
everything's are going with YouTube and
we still want to keep our creative
endeavors groaning even higher and
higher we decided we'll launch one for
you guys and so it would really mean the
world to us if you could go just check
out our patreon page is of course a link
in the description box to go there if
you feel like you can donate whatever
you can donate it would be especially
amazing and we'd be super duper grateful
to you guys for that like I mentioned in
the video with the algorithm change you
to losing 750 million dollars in ad
revenue has really caused a lot of
things to you know dip what are not to
lose face too much here but a lot of
things a bit it's safe to say that
everyone is affected by X this is a an
interesting place to make a living and
sometimes you got to diversify oh that
and then and this is a cool chance for
us to get in better touch with you guys
you know obviously not everyone's going
to go to the patreon for those of you
that do I mean we can probably build a
pretty cool community over there and
yeah make it worth your while and we're
always you know open to constructive
feedback we're never going to be putting
a time and investment into our patreon
account this isn't going to be something
we're just a one-time announcement and
then bye-bye for those who do donate and
do get in both on our patreon account
you will be getting exclusive stuff for
you guys so would really mean the world
to us and also to beyond all this
algorithm stuff and YouTube losing money
all that we really want to keep creating
content for you guys and
things have been a little bit scary we
want to make sure we could do that a
comfortable and consistent pace to keep
producing because the last thing we'd
want it to leave YouTube or make less
videos for you guys and you know we
upload daily we want to keep that flow
going consistently as much as possible
before all this stuff happened we were
being suggested to create a patreon
account because we only do sketches like
every two to three months we want to
make that more of a monthly thing and it
is like every like two to three months
things sometimes it's a little bit
longer because that takes time energy a
lot of editing goes into that you got to
get a crew together that'll cost like
money 14 to do but your guide to support
we can do a lot more of those and for
you guys you haven't seen our sketches
they're on the playlist of real rejects
experiments people really love them then
every time we do want people like we
want more we want more more like kind of
hard to do yeah it's a little more
challenging than people might think it
is when it's just a two-man crew for
most of this then also we're operating
off a lot of the same equipment that we
started with you know five years ago
some of it is just time for repairs and
upgrades and things and sudden you guys
will see that you know whatever you put
in it's our hope that you'll see that in
the channel so whatever you guys donate
it would all be an investment into
keeping this channel running smoothly
consistently us being able to work
comfortably and keep producing content
for you lovely people yeah we love all
you guys we wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for you do the yeah I like it
we're not the most comfortable talking
about this day on it's kind of it's
weird for us and a few years we've had
the channel we've never asked for
something like this we've never said hey
dude so this is our your own leisure yes
is just your own choice to do it
whatever you think it might be worth if
you could donate you know like three
dollars or whatever amount you can that
would ever be amazed balls to us
seriously we'd be super grateful and
again it'll keep the channel alive and
well yeah especially especially as the
landscape of YouTube changes and we
learn what hazards there are tamiya
afraid of also very soon we're going to
officially have a t-shirt line opening
up we already have about five designs
done we wanted we just want a couple
more before we officially launched it we
will never open to syrup or never
be a brand new store on burbank
boulevard downtown Berlin it's going to
be an online probably through
spreadshirt it's a play on the word
spread yes I get it now yeah probably
through spreadshirt we got a few designs
already up and ready to go but we want
it before we make an official
announcement launch about it we just
want a few more up there so aids you
know a lot more options choose from and
the day we actually started the patron
because we'd have to pay trying to count
up for a little bit but we waited a
while to make the announcement but
subscriber name house Heisenberg he
found our page randomly and donated five
bucks so how a Heisenberg thank you so
much for doing that my friend that's
amazing that we didn't even like we
didn't put a link out there or anything
no mention of it and he just found it
and was like all right look I'll donate
to you guys I think Twitter
automatically sends out like oh you have
a patreon page yeah that's what I mean
like in five bucks is not a lot of money
but it means a shit-ton to it feels like
a lot of money I think about it and what
donate five bucks a month building a lot
of money to me anything I commit to but
if it's a dollar feels like a lot so is
that about we you know we've got a
little over 40 to 50 k subs right now
and even if just a fraction of valuing
even if you chip in a dollar that yeah
we'll help the channel keep going and
we're gonna do again we're just two
people with managing all this stuff but
we're gonna do our best to make it worth
your while at least you know make sure
to thank you guys and highlight you guys
you know who takes the time to go out
and support us because it helps keep
this channel literally live if you don't
feel like donating just please continue
watching our videos that's a motive we
at the end of the date I thought we'd
really give a [ __ ] about ya go visit our
patreon page link in the description box
just type in the real reject on patreon
if you want to do that subscribe to the
real rejects wreaths Egeria twitter and
instagram social media manager of
Blumhouse in the real rejects and thank
you guys i love all of you especially
the haters oh yeah yeah they're they're
the ones you're going to flood no wonder
to serve the most yeah we should make
that a patreon perk actually like if you
pay a certain amount there will be a
special stream where you can just put
all your hate directly and will respond
to this patreon is for the people who
write when we upload immediately dislike
our videos the p
or subscribe just to hit the dislike
button within a minute of us uploading
this is for you yeah I guess